if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helix sleep.com
pacman
all right welcome everybody to november
it's a new week we're going to start
with something really instructive today
last week the week before i talked about
sort of the inherent difficulty
of confronting these conspiracy
theorists or conspiracy delusionists
with the idea of i'm just going to show
them how each one of their claims is
wrong and that it's really difficult to
do this in real time i talked about a
recent sam harris podcast episode where
he outlines this very well when he's
asked what about having someone like
brett weinstein on
and arguing with him about each one of
his points related to vaccines and
ivermectin etc and sam harris very
astutely pointed out it's really easy to
start 10 small fires and if you can only
put out eight or nine of them it kind of
ends up looking like you didn't really
address this elephant in the room there
was a really good post on
our subreddit which mentioned this and
has a link to an interview that happened
on friday where bill maher interviews
sean spicer and this user reflex point
actually says uh bill maher versus sean
spicer and why fact-checking conspiracy
theorists in real time is a problem
david was recently mentioning sam
harris's statement about why it can be
dangerous to argue with conspiracy
theorists in a live format because if
they just start gish galloping a bunch
of nonsense in real time it can be
difficult to come out of it looking like
you won and sean spicer does a perfect
example of that when giving his reasons
to question election integrity he'll
point to some obscure rule that changed
in some battleground state and then
claim it's suspect and bill is supposed
to know about it and if he doesn't then
bill must be wrong and having confidence
in the election results so let's take a
look i'm going to play this two and a
half minutes uninterrupted
see if you can keep track of all the
different assertions that sean spicer
makes i'm keeping track and then we're
going to go through them in a moment
what about what about the election was
rigged and trump really won is that i
think there are some serious problems
with the elections here we go no no time
out hold on name when you look at
pennsylvania wisconsin nevada the idea
that we changed rules running up to an
election in terms of how about it when
it was counted do you think pennsylvania
the law signed by a democratic governor
2019 acts 77 signed by governor wolf
said that all ballots had to be entered
there was a pandemic that's why they
changed the law they okay there was no
time to do that
so you should just never well you would
have no there wasn't there wasn't plenty
of time to pass legislation and all of
these others this is a rabbit hole you
want to go down avoid the question did
trump win or lose the election i don't
know well there you go because the world
does if you know they first
tell me how many votes that got cast
illegally and not according to the
system
but this was litigated in every courts
even republicans who were in charge of
the vote came down on the side of this
election was fairly adjudicated you
yourself said right after the election
they asked you about fraud you have said
i have seen no evidence correct i
haven't but what i have seen is a state
there's a difference so imaginary no no
there is a difference what
pennsylvania's supreme court did what
wisconsin's clerks did they let people
wisconsin does not have a provision in
their law to let people vote early in
person it has an absentee ballot
provision people set up
tables in parks in madison wisconsin and
allowed people to come without
identification in pennsylvania they were
allowed to vote without identification
no postmark on the ballot in violation
of acts 77 signed by a democratic
governor in 2019 and the answer is well
then don't worry about it because it was
a pandemic well what's the next thing
that you can just blow away a law is a
law until it's changed you don't get to
pick what you want to follow depending
on what's happening outside okay this
again this was looked at
exhaustively it's not so that's not true
what was looked at so for example in
wisconsin the court ruled four to three
okay sean i get it you know what you're
looking at you accuse me
you said your piece you said your piece
i haven't looked at this you're like
that kid in school who's right
no
no who who has to do has to answer about
the book report so reads one page very
carefully that nobody else read and then
does the thing on that and then we don't
know what you're talking about you do
but we know that what i do know
okay
so
so that's a lot
so think about all of the different
things that bill maher
in principle or in theory had to be
ready to refute and how difficult it is
now we've done it after the fact but
just look at how much time this is going
to take me so sean spicer mentions
pennsylvania wisconsin and nevada and
says they changed rules leading up to an
election he mentions a 2019 pennsylvania
law signed by government governor wolf
that says ballots have to be in by 8 pm
on election day he's asked did trump win
or lose he doesn't know because he
doesn't know the results in different
states he asks how many votes were
illegally cast he says the pennsylvania
supreme court court
and the wisconsin clerks
changed rules and wisconsin has no
provision to let people vote early in
person only absentee and that there were
parks just letting people vote with no
id pennsylvania allowed people to vote
without id and with no postmark on the
ballot and that violates act 77 and then
he mentions the wisconsin court ruled
four to three he doesn't say he doesn't
actually say what they ruled or what the
case was
so look at all of this different stuff
we now have to deal with in order to
simply say hey
uh trump lost and that's it
on pennsylvania wisconsin and nevada he
says well there were problems
and he just lists them
but he doesn't really explain what the
plot problems were in 2020 the results
were biden 303 and trump 235. if you
flip all three of those states
trump gets the 270 votes he needs but
that's if you flip all three
let's say sean spicer is right but about
two of those three states
and what he's right about actually means
that trump won two of those three states
biden still wins the election in that
case so even at its face he's throwing
out three states as if trump probably
won them just to demonstrate that in one
of those trump actually won would be a
herculean effort for which there's no
evidence but if you only are able to
successfully demonstrate
trump really won two of those three
biden still wins that election so that's
a real red herring
second rules changed leading up to the
election
some states did change election
procedures without legislation but
that's no big deal we've studied this
already i already told you rebecca
greene election law professor at college
of william and mary said it's often the
case that election statutes have gaps
that don't
account for particular situations like
the pandemic so
just because a decision was made
not from the legislature it was made by
the governor's office or a public health
board or whatever that's really not a
big deal spicer asserts that it happened
as if that's a problem it's not actually
a problem it's common
many states also changed election rules
because of the pandemic blue states and
red states did it states that trump won
did it and states biden one did it and
big shocker these republicans only ever
talk about the fact that states biden
one did it north dakota changed rules
due to the pandemic
not through the legislature leading up
to the election so did arkansas so did
texas they all made state changes in
that way trump won those they don't make
a peep about those
then spicer mentions a 2019 pennsylvania
law signed by governor wolf which says
ballots have to be in by 8 pm
it's true that pennsylvania law
did require ballots to be in by 8 pm on
election day but before the 2020
election the state supreme court of
pennsylvania extended the deadline
so ballots could be received by mail
until 5 p.m on the friday of election
week if they're either postmarked by
election day or have a missing or
illegible postmark they did a new
deadline it was dealt with the
pennsylvania supreme court dealt with
that now if sean spicer wants to argue
the pennsylvania supreme court is
illegitimate in so doing that's a
different argument but it's been dealt
with in a legal way that is accepted as
a valid way to change when absentee
ballots can be received
then spicer says well how many
votes were illegally cast
it's such a vague question it's
meaningless because his definition of
illegal might be it was received after 8
pm on election day in pennsylvania
but as i told you the state supreme
court already dealt with that so what
does he really mean by illegal votes
wisconsin he says had no provision to
let people vote early in person only
absentee
well wisconsin didn't used to permit
early in-person voting but then they
decided to in 2021 they can do that he
says well the clerks decided the clerks
have the authority to decide that
they decided it legally and changed that
rule
it's not actually a red flag the way he
says and then lastly he mentions the
wisconsin court ruled 4-3 and he doesn't
tell you what they ruled well i looked
into it the conservative-led wisconsin
supreme court ruled four to three
not to throw out 220 000 ballots that
the trump campaign wanted thrown out
spicer mentions it
look the wisconsin court ruled four to
three yeah but what did they rule it was
a it was a conservative majority supreme
court
which decided you can't just throw out
these hundred two hundred and twenty
thousand ballots um so
each of these things when you analyze
them is really nothing it's not a
smoking gun it's not a red flag but if
you watch the two and a half minutes i
played for you
it might seem like bill maher didn't
really refute everything and this is
exactly the challenge that sam harris
has recently talked about when asked why
aren't you debating more of these
vaccine skeptics or ivermectin advocates
or whatever
because they show up and they go wait a
second you didn't see the bangladeshi
study you which showed what you know
whatever no i didn't see it oof wow you
and you think you know what's going on
the bangladeshi study may be something
it may not be something really good
example
glad that it was posted to our subreddit
uh donald trump reemerged over the
halloween weekend after weeks of simply
publishing unhinged statement after
statement to his website in an interview
with fox news's janine pirro now it was
halloween weekend this interview that
trump gave was way scarier than any
costume or any horror movie that's for
sure so let's jump in
uh trump saying just days before
tomorrow's virginia gubernatorial
election trump arguing that his
endorsement is worth a lot he almost
always wins and he has endorsed glenn
younkin
let's take a look at the clip if i
endorse somebody they win
if i endorse somebody they win i think
i'm 148 and two
that's a pretty good number you endorsed
junkin
and i did endorse yunkan and we're gonna
see i hope it's not gonna be three okay
do you understand that i did i endorse
him strongly he's a good man now the
funny thing about the yunkan endorsement
is that if yunkan does ultimately win
tomorrow trump is obviously going to say
hey that's another win in my column
that's another one that i endorsed and
who won
if yunkan loses tomorrow yunkan has
actually been distancing himself from
donald trump for the last month or so uh
he appears to have calculated that
trump's involvement may not actually
help him defeat terry mcauliffe tomorrow
so if yunkan loses of course trump's
going to say you know listen i would
have brought him a win
but yunkan didn't embrace me that's why
it's really yunkan's fault so trump's
going to take advantage of tomorrow's
results no matter what but what are the
what are the actual numbers on the facts
trump's record is not that good on
endorsements in the 2018 midterms uh
trump endorsed 75 candidates and
55 percent of them won so trump's record
in 2018 was 55 wins 45 losses 55 wins
and he's mostly endorsing incumbents so
it's actually not so great a record and
ballot pedia looked at trump's overall
record during his entire presidency they
tracked 305 endorsements that trump made
and um trump's record
in 2020 for example was that 77 of his
endorses won
again there is a bias to success because
trump mostly endorses incumbents and
incumbency has a huge advantage so it's
really not that great of a record let's
look at a little bit more of this um
interview that trump gave janine pirro
and just pick up a couple of just wacky
things trump says okay if there's one
word that could sum up the biden
administration it would be crisis
there's the energy prices the supply
chain crisis the coveted crisis if you
look back on the last 10 months of the
biden administration what grade would
you give them well it's probably the
worst presidency in history i can't
imagine i used to say jimmy carter
not a big fan of bush getting us into
the middle east to be honest with you i
think this is though
the worst in the history of our country
if you look at afghanistan and that
horrible thing that happened to our
nation
with these young people being killed and
by the way so badly injured we have over
20 no arms so remember when asked donald
trump has not been able to articulate
anything he would have done differently
in afghanistan uh let's go to
um
i believe this is a discussion of gas
prices and this is very interesting
because it's an opportunity for trump to
be honest but he's not take a look
average american family spending an
extra 175 dollars a month gas prices are
up to seven dollars in california five
dollars in new york we can't afford
these people and joe biden when he was
asked about gas prices what he's going
to do about it he says i don't see
anything that's going to reduce
significantly reduce gas prices in the
near future he doesn't know no he
doesn't have any idea look
one of the things i was most proud about
our country became energy independent
not only the middle east we didn't need
russia we didn't need anybody we had our
own we had more than them
we were number one by far over saudi
arabia and you know this and russia
number one by far i had the pipelines
going keystone xl pipeline
amazingly i ended the russian pipeline i
was not good to russia i got along well
with russia i got along well with putin
but they weren't happy with trump i can
tell you that
but biden opened up this big massive
pipeline all over europe but he closed
down the exo and i have to say because
you heard it a thousand times more
importantly we're energy
independent no longer
i was so proud of that first time really
in history understand that there has
been no appreciable change
in the energy supply
configuration of the united states um in
the 10 months joe biden has been
president i mean it's just trump cites
nothing there it just hasn't happened
it's imaginary
you know they say 75 years but i don't
believe we were ever energy independent
we were
energy independent we were doing so much
the the prices it was a dollar
eighty-seven a gallon
okay if you look at you look at the
numbers the credits now
yesterday they had in a certain section
of california seven dollars and seventy
cents it's always the lead
it's gonna follow and it's gonna go a
lot higher than that
and biden sent people
to go see russia
saudi arabia and other members of opec
that we need help because we don't have
enough now when you talk about inflation
the biggest factor so it would be really
i actually think joe biden should be
applauded for what he said during the
town hall he said as as a president i
the one thing i can do probably only
drops gas 30 cents
that is refreshingly honest because when
it's convenient presidents love to
pretend that they they really have
control over gas prices we're talking
about global markets we're talking about
supply chains that move really slowly
now in terms of trump claiming gas was
super cheap he mentioned a dollar 87 a
gallon for the four years that trump was
in office gas prices were under two
bucks a gallon for only two months april
and may of 2020 and that's because
demand went to zero
because of the start of the pandemic and
it was where people were traveling as
little as we've seen them travel drive
around work from home started etc it
would be really refreshing if more
presidents said hey you know what i know
this is a popular political football but
as presidents we have very little
control over gas prices we have the
strategic petroleum reserve which on on
a medium-term basis could reduce prices
a little but this is really much bigger
than us but of course trump doesn't do
that horrifying disinformation if you
have the stomach for it
check out the entire interview it's
available on foxnews.com we're going to
leave it there send me your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at dpakman
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video remember that you
can support our show and the work we do
and get some really cool extras in so
doing by signing up for a membership at
joinpacman.com you'll get the daily
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show so
many great things including priority
access to our viewer town halls one of
which we had a couple of weeks ago we've
got another one scheduled for
soon i'll announce the date once i have
it but it'll be probably in the next
month month or five weeks or so
you know last week or maybe it was the
week before
i told you about a report that looked at
how coveted denialism and coveted
conspiracy delusions
have been a great feeder into
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and all
of the different overlaps that exist
about shadow government both being
controlled by jews and
wanting everybody injected with tracking
devices or you know whatever the case
may be the point is this report found
how online covet denialism and covet
conspiracies
are very much interlaced with
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and
white supremacy white nationalism etc
now anytime there's a report it can be
sort of abstract and we might not
see or understand in practice the way
that this comes together i have an
example for you that was sent to me by a
few viewers today we're going to be
looking at video here of um from a few
days ago i believe this was wednesday or
thursday of last week this is the
chandler governing board study session
and regular business meeting
and there is a woman who is going to
speak and you're going to listen to her
momentarily and it is really the perfect
storm it's an amalgam of anti-vaxx
anti-mask anti-critical race theory
delusions ignorance shadow government
conspiracism and of course she ties it
all together in a nice little bow
and says it's all the jews folks it's
really all the jews so one race is
responsible the jews are making the
vaccines the jews control the shadow
government the jews control the
pharmaceutical companies and this is
what we're talking about when we say
these are the ways that these things
come together it may be one of the most
insane clips i've seen since this all
started let's just jump right into it
warning you know if you don't want kids
to see this i would understand getting
them out of the room let's listen my
name is melanie rattler
i'm a veterinarian i was a former
teacher in phoenix union high school
district i'm a cloning expert with 35
years experience
and i was a consultant to the cdc i've
owned a pharmacy um so do we know if any
of those things are true she was a vet
she was a teacher
she's an expert on cloning she was a
consultant to the cdc presumably i don't
know on something related to veterinary
stuff and she owned a pharmacy did she
own
a human pharmacy or a veterinary
pharmacy
we don't know if any of it's true i want
to tell you that
um
this vaccine
this covet vaccine is a deadly poison
that's it i'm just going to tell you
that
everybody that takes it is damaging
their immune system
and
they're talking about uh this um being
given to children now it's going to
destroy them
now
it's already been tested on tens of
thousands of kids in clinical trials and
the kids are fine i need to do more
research on it i'm an expert on it and
i'm telling you that's what it's doing
what's also interesting is that all of
the expertise she claims to have which
includes being a veterinarian consultant
to the cdc pharmacy owner teacher expert
on cloning
none of that relates to vaccines
you would imagine that she would have
mentioned in that litany of expertise
that she's also an expert on vaccines
she didn't
all right the next thing is my next
topic is the crt
um
i agree with what both of these people
said um but you know what
if you want to talk about racism if you
want to bring it in then let's bring it
in
let's get to the bottom of
the bottom of it we're talking about
white supremacy
okay let's get to the very bottom of it
every one of these things the deep state
the cabal the swamp the elite you can't
mention it
but i will there is one race
that owns all the pharmaceutical
companies and these vaccines aren't safe
they aren't effective and they aren't
free
you know that you're paying for it
through the increase in gas prices the
increase in food
prices you're paying for this
and it's being taken from your money and
given to
these um
pharmaceutical companies
and if you want to bring
raised into this it's the jews
so a smattering of applause there as she
ties together
all of these different things inflation
gas prices critical race theory the
vaccines through the pharmaceutical
companies the shadow government
it's all
the jews according to this woman
this is the prototypical example of how
this stuff works and it just works so
well for them it feels
so cohesive and and coherent and logical
um this is this is what we were talking
about last week with the report
about how this this covet stuff feeds
right into the anti-semitism and again
you know the the framing of you're not
allowed to say it but i'm going to
you the same group is in control of all
this stuff the shadow government
and the gas prices the i guess i guess
the jews on the gas stations is what
she's saying and the various products
maybe the most insane clip i've seen
since all of this started
hey this is uh this is starting to now
become
very very obvious in terms of the
concern the panic that donald trump has
about the truth getting out as to what
he was up to and who he was meeting with
in the days leading up to the trump
riots we've known now for a little while
that donald trump is doing everything he
can
to get joe biden to assert executive
privilege over
documents related to his actions
leading up to the trump riots and so far
joe biden has said he's not going to do
that
we now have learned thanks to some
really great reporting from cnn crime
and justice reporter caitlin polance
that donald trump is acting desperately
to hide his daily schedule in the days
leading up to the january 6th riot why
would he want to do that well
we can infer
that if it became known what he was up
to and who he was meeting with there
would be a lot of overlap with people
that played roles in ginning up and
inciting the january 6 riots maybe even
worse maybe even worse so let's go first
to this was
this is based on reporting by caitlin
pollants which we'll get to cnn reporter
caitlin collins tweeted about this
saying quote
major news overnight per a sworn
declaration from the national archives
trump is trying to keep more than 700
pages of files out of the hands of the
january 6th committee including 30 pages
of his daily schedule visitor logs and
call records for trump pence caitlyn
poland's reports this includes documents
from trump's top aides including three
handwritten notes from mark meadows
proposed talking points for kaylee
mcinanny files from stephen miller and
deputy council pat philbin the white
house daily diary and drafts of remarks
regarding the national archives says
trump's wants to says trump wants to
assert executive oh sorry for remarks
regarding january 6 the national archive
says trump wants to assert privilege
over a handwritten note from former
chief of staff mark meadows files
listing potential or scheduled briefings
and telephone calls concerning the
january 6th certification and other
election issues
trump doesn't want it to be known
who he was talking to about how to block
the certification on january 6th and we
have you know some pretty sensible
guesses as to why the report from cnn's
caitlyn paul ends worth reading in full
um specifics it says specifics about
former president trump's efforts to keep
secret the support from his white house
for overturning his loss of the 2020
election were revealed in late night
court filings detailing more than 700
pages of handwritten notes draft
documents and daily logs related to
january 6th this is the first time for
the first time a sworn declaration of
what trump wants to keep secret
the records show trump wants to keep
secret include handwritten memos from
his chief of staff
call logs of trump and pence and white
house visitor records additional court
records revealed early saturday morning
trump's court case is a crucial and
potentially historic legal fight over
the authority of a former president to
protect his term in office the house's
subpoena power and the reach of
executive privilege but it's not only
that it's also an attempt for us not to
know the degree to which donald trump
was involved in planning and had
foreknowledge of what ultimately took
place on january 6th the trump riots
what would his schedule expose well it's
speculation at this point because we
only know the gist of what he wants to
cover up not the content because so far
it's not been made public but maybe
there were too many meetings with people
involved or suspected to be involved in
the trump riots maybe trump actually had
phone calls with some of the people that
organized and carried out violence we
just don't know and i'm conceding that
this is speculation but this is not the
behavior of an innocent person now hold
on a second
hold on a second
i'm not saying trump doesn't deserve due
process
i'm not saying anything about that
people are innocent until proven guilty
in a court of law and it doesn't mean
that trump is guilty so everybody relax
i know that the um uh i the there's a
contingent where every time i say this
is not the behavior of an innocent
person someone writes and says david
that ignores due process people aren't
guilty in the u.s until proven innocent
this isn't a court of law this is my
show and it is my opinion colloquially
that this is not the behavior of an
innocent person that doesn't mean he's
guilty of anything in a in in a criminal
trial it's not what i'm saying he's not
even been charged uh the one other
thought about this
trump seems to sort of be telling the
january 6th committee exactly where to
look for the most relevant evidence
about his behavior
by making it clear what it is he doesn't
want revealed
last thing
all of this relates to the release of
these in these documents
to the january 6th committee
if they are released to the january 6
committee there is no guarantee that
they will actually be made public to us
they may leak of course that that that's
always a a risk but this is not about
making these documents public this is
about making them available to the
january 6th committee
what do you believe
is in trump's schedule and call logs
that he wants to cover up let me know
we'll have more on this on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so as we continue to wait for and wonder
is republican congressman matt gates
going to be charged
for possibly child sex trafficking and
or other crimes the investigation is
ongoing matt gates has retained lawyers
expert in defending against sex crimes
as we wonder about that his behavior
continues to become more and more
outrageous and um over the weekend matt
gates actually i guess you could call it
joking i'm not really sure
matt gates joked about blowing up
capital metal detectors
with explosives
um this of course relates to the metal
detectors that were installed at the
capitol
at least in part because it was believed
that some republican members of congress
including lauren beaubert maybe others
madison cawthorne has talked about being
being armed being protected uh bringing
weapons onto the house floor
so we're gonna go through this piece by
piece
mediaite article says while campaigning
for a republican congressional candidate
in central for florida on saturday
congressman matt gates complained about
the metal detectors in the capital lying
about why they were installed and going
so far as to joke about blowing them up
with explosives
the former the florida congressman was
in lake county to campaign for florida
state rape rep anthony sabatini sabatini
who was running for congress in 2022 and
shares gates support for former
president donald trump
gates mentioned congresswoman lauren
bobert's objection to the metal
detectors that were installed in the
capitol complex shortly after the trump
riots multiple republican lawmakers
loudly complained about the metal
detectors claiming they were a violation
of their constitutional rights they
weren't and beaubert was among those who
attempted to circumvent the screening
by walking around the metal detectors or
refusing
to allow her bag to be searched all
right so let's take a look at the first
clip here here is matt gates talking
about blowing up the metal detectors in
the house with either tannerite or c4
explosive my friend lauren bobert from
colorado
she
they put in metal detectors on the floor
of the house because it's like a five
foot nothing woman she carries a firearm
for her personal protection so oh they
got triggered by that i said man
is it is it tana knight or c4 we want to
put in those metal detectors when we
blow them up and we take them
yeah
now
in all seriousness
this is the exact type of thing that
causes stochastic violence if not
stochastic terror
aside from whether it's even appropriate
absent any real world implications for a
sitting member of congress to be joking
about or maybe not joking uh talking
about blowing up the chamber in which he
works and votes and in which legislative
duties are carried out whether you can
say that's fine or it's not fine or
whatever
if you have an understanding if you
recognize and realize
the degree to which
disproportionately the types of people
that follow someone like matt gates
are folks who um
would be willing to do violence in real
life to solve political issues
you start to realize this could actually
encourage someone to go and to try to
set off a bomb at the house now would
they get into where the metal detectors
are maybe not
but that's not really a defense this is
we've talked about stochastic terror
given a large enough audience if you
hammer on and hammer on and hammer on an
idea and radicalize people against a
person or institution it starts to
become statistically likely that someone
it wouldn't be predictable exactly who
but that whoa sorry for hitting my mic
that someone is going to go out and um
actually act on that now as a reminder
we recently had more context to this
lauren bobert was recently interviewed
by a cultural critic and arbiter of
ideas dave rubin and lauren bobert sort
of smiled and laughed and kind of took
credit supposedly for the metal
detectors even being there remember this
from last week nancy pelosi has called
me the enemy within um we have metal
detectors outside of the house chambers
because of me
and uh
or so so it seems so they now are
ridiculing what are actions that had to
be taken
because members of congress posed a risk
in terms of the weapons they were trying
to bring in as i said last week it's not
something to be proud about
that your place of work had to put in
metal detectors because of your actions
it's not that i would be humiliated if
that were the case
also from this same very strange
appearance here matt gates says he
thinks democrats are going to see
how many republican votes are there and
then they will illegally create
democratic votes to counter that sort of
like as a one-to-one thing completely
baseless no evidence of this take a look
at matt gates's suggestion i really
think they like in fulton county georgia
i think they wait and they see how many
votes the republicans got in the other
parts of the state and then that's how
many they need to like will into
existence so that's a completely
unfalsifiable claim
um you can always look at election
results and say oh
democrats won by a thousand
democrats actually really lost by a
thousand but they checked how many
republican votes they were and then they
created 2 000 democratic votes to take a
thousand vote lead completely
unfalsifiable hasn't happened no
evidence that it's happened no evidence
that democrats have attempted it
just more poisoning the well that type
of thing only works on ignorant voters
there's no evidence that that's done and
it would be completely unfalsifiable
uh just look you can look at any
election result and in fact they're
doing it mike pillow does it and these
people do it they say no no no no no
trump really won wisconsin by 200 000.
really where's the evidence well they
won't give us the evidence oh okay well
then so how we
this is this they he really won
you can't falsify a lot of these things
and that's what makes them great fodder
for low information voters
all right this next story
at first i wasn't going to cover it at
all the story is that at an atlanta
braves game over the weekend at the
world series
um donald trump participated in the
tomahawk chop now the tomahawk chop is
this sort of ritual or routine or you
know i don't know what you want to call
it uh that is done at the atlanta braves
baseball games it also has been done
elsewhere the exeter chiefs
use the tomahawk chop but it's it's
quite well known for
the atlanta braves and the idea is that
it's sort of a chopping motion done with
your hand as if you're holding an axe
it's a reference to
uh scalping by native americans and
what's problematic about it you know
every time sometimes it's like people
play really dumb they go what what's
xenophobic or what's what you know you i
don't know whether the right word is
right word is xenophobic or racist or
whatever
but you're essentially um portraying as
savages native american peoples in the
united states and um of course the more
we learn about native populations the
more we learn that there was quite a lot
here they had complex societies they
were developing uh uh technology you
know it's
it it's just a historical but it's also
just really kind of vile and the story
that first started floating around was
oh trump does the tomahawk chop and it's
like yeah whatever trump's an idiot i'm
not going to cover it but then the
storyline became that during that
melania trump appears to turn away and
look disgusted and kind of roll her eyes
at trump as all of this is going on and
it's again this whole thing of oh
melania's being held captive melania
really hates trump and all of this sort
of thing
for me the real story is that they were
both there doing the tomahawk chop so
let's start with the first video this is
the tomahawk chop taking place and both
melania and trump are doing it if you
can't see it
you're not missing that much it's trump
and melania doing the tomahawk chapter
take a look
[Music]
okay so it's cringy it's just it's just
gross like it uh it's just what what the
hell is the former president doing it's
crazy that this is even done
that's for me the real story that trump
participated in that that was a blip but
then the big story became this moment
that i'm playing for you here on repeat
where melania smiles and this was either
you know right before right after the
tomahawk chop and she then just kind of
grimaces and rolls her eyes and turns
away and it's again this whole thing of
melania doesn't like donald trump is she
safe is she being held hostage if she's
really that disgusted with trump she
certainly hasn't shown disgust
with the specific ideas and xenophobia
and backwards thinking that trump
promulgated and emulated during his
presidency she would show up and talk
about a lot of the same things that
donald trump did when in her rare public
appearances there would be some
occasional little apparent disagreement
but for me the story here is not oh
melania's disgusted again and maybe she
hates trump maybe she is and maybe
that's true but she's not acted on it in
any real way for me the real story is
the fact that the president and the the
former president and the former first
lady
are doing the tomahawk chop at a
baseball game which is just a horrible
horrible
um
again just like a portrayal of of of
unilateral savage savagery from the very
native populations that were decimated
um by the arriving settlers of what is
now the united states so it's like the
prototypical example of the real story
being being missed as uh
what was happening was was horrifying um
just from yahoo news melania trump
attended a world series baseball game
cameras showed her quick pivot from
smiling with her husband to turning away
and rolling her eyes twitter also caught
the moment igniting discussion on the
platform melania trump strikes again
it's pretty pathetic her her strikes uh
have been
um
superficial in nature
and meaningless in substance and that's
really the story here so if you disagree
if you think that it that her reaction
really is the big story versus the fact
that they were both participating in the
tomahawk chop uh let me know let me know
i i'm open to being convinced but for me
the real story is the tomahawk chop
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show so last week we had a big
discussion across multiple days about
should progressives just now at this
point work to kill the spending and
infrastructure bill that's been
completely gutted i gave you a list last
week of
five six major pieces
of the proposals that had been floating
around that are believed to be
completely dead in the water
and i said at this point i'm okay with
progressive saying kill it
i often
say if it does some good then it should
be supported because it's a step in the
right direction it will help some people
and any opportunity to help people
should be taken
i started to go in the direction last
week of there's so little here that this
will serve as a victory for centrist
democrats by saying we don't have to do
anything progressives want it will serve
as a victory for republicans for saying
the more we obstruct the less they're
going to get even if we're not in
control and it's nothing for
progressives we've got a voicemail
related to killing the bill which i'm
going to play for you in a little bit
one bit of news is that bernie sanders
has not given up uh senator bernie
sanders appeared on cnn yesterday
and made it very clear that he's still
pushing at least to get lower drug
prices into the bill now if he was able
to do that is lower drug prices price
controls on on medications and
prescriptions would that be enough to to
say well okay just for that alone
progressives should support it we'll get
to that in a second let's first listen
to some of this interview he gave you
have said there are major gaps in this
plan several several of your priorities
paid leave
dental and vision for medicare giving
the government power to negotiate lower
prescription drug prices for seniors
that's not in the deal uh you saw that
house progresses
endorse the compromise do you
well it's not in the bill yet but what i
can tell you donna we are working right
now i spent all of yesterday on the
telephone look we are paying the highest
prices in the world
for prescription drugs
uh the pharmaceutical industry has spent
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars to make certain that americans
pay ten times more for some drugs than
the canadians or the mexicans do that
fight continues
uh and the fight to expand medicare look
poll after poll shows that the american
people understand it is not acceptable
that elderly people have teeth in their
mouth that are rotting they can't digest
their food they can't they don't have
the vision that they need in order to
read a newspaper so we are continuing
that effort so can i just pains me very
much i'm sorry go ahead no i just want
to just make sure that i understand what
you're saying you're saying you're
continuing that effort you want to still
add it before the house votes you want
to add it to the the bill absolutely
look uh we're working as everybody
should know we're on two separate bills
you got a bipartisan infrastructure bill
which will finally begin to address the
reality that our roads and our bridges
and our water systems are crumbling
that's one bill but we want to move both
bills in tandem and the second bill the
bill that deals with the needs of the
working class of this country in terms
of child care in terms of pre-k that
deals with the existential threat of
climate that bill is still being worked
on literally today it will be worked on
tomorrow i believe we're making some
progress in making it even stronger than
it is
if it if you don't succeed in that
progress will you support the the
framework as it currently stands
what the white house released at the end
of the week
well
all i will tell you is we have a very
very strong bill uh and it deals with uh
the fact that
uh we are gonna start paying attention
to the needs of working parents continue
that 300 we're going to build affordable
housing uh we're going to make sure that
elderly people and people with
disabilities can stay at home rather
than be forced so bernie goes into talk
you know these are these are talking
points that we've heard before but so
the fundamental question ultimately gets
to let's say bernie and other democrats
get lower prescription drug price
provisions into the bill then
should progressives support it
in my mind
that actually would be enough to say
support the bill
and it wouldn't change the fact that it
would still be missing and lacking so
many things that were talked about early
uh a tax that target you know between
these two bills tax that targets the
very very richest billionaires uh paid
leave child care you know there's so
medicare expansion so many things that i
am in favor of and that are good and
that are necessary and that should be in
there
um all of those things would still be
gone but the degree to which the
american people are getting screwed when
it comes to prescription drug costs and
it's so popular to talk about lowering
prescription drug costs both democrats
and republicans talk about it all the
time trump talked about it he didn't do
it um but the the mechanisms through
which they would do it of course differ
there's no question about that
um it actually would be so materially
useful to so many people particularly
seniors the way that bernie sanders is
talking about because of how medicare
works
that again i'm talking pragmatically i
know the optics are terrible but that is
so good for so many people that i would
probably say don't kill the bill
get the bill done if that's in there now
how likely that is to happen and how
much of this is bernie either posturing
or trying to put public pressure on uh
colleagues and other we just don't know
we just these negotiations are happening
constantly between different parties and
this is why my coverage of this has
basically been listen the entire process
is a grandstanding quagmire there's a
lot of this that is just the worst of
politics and worst of the dc beltway it
doesn't relate to people who are just
trying to afford gas trying to afford
food trying to afford medication it just
it doesn't connect this it's so abstract
and and uh uh um idealized in some way
by those who think oh big negotiate it's
it's a lot of bs that's going on and i
get all of that but if there's really
going to be something
actually done and if you trust bernie if
you're a bernie supporter if you believe
bernie does the right things or tries to
then you would imagine that if he gets
that into the bill it's going to be
materially substantive i think i'm
probably back on and say just just pass
it and get it done and then let's move
on and try to do more and do the next
iteration if you disagree with me on the
value of prescription drug price
controls as reason alone to support the
bill i want to hear from you reasonable
people can disagree but it seems like an
important thing to me
a white house press secretary jenn saki
has tested positive for covid and of
course the question was well when was
she with joe biden and what's going on
and it actually turns out that she
hasn't been around joe biden for a
little bit and is not on joe biden's
current trip to europe apparently
because many in her family had tested
positive so here's the report from cnn
saki test positive for covid last saw
biden tuesday
white house press secretary jen saki who
dropped off president joe biden's
international trip shortly before he
departed has tested positive for
coronavirus after members of her
household did
saki said she last saw biden tuesday
outside while masked before the
president departed for rome
for the group of 20 summit and that she
tested negative several times in between
saki said she was disclosing the
positive test result quote out of an
abundance of transparency adding she
experienced mild symptoms and is working
remotely it's unlikely saki could have
infected biden with covid19 several
physicians told cnn sunday based on the
timeline of miz saki's testing negative
for multiple days following her last
encounter with biden which was also
outside and masked therefore very low
risk in and of itself dr leanna wen a
cnn medical analyst and former baltimore
city health commissioner said in an
email
the white house announced thursday sake
would no longer join biden on his trip
abroad for the at least the first few
days citing a family emergency
white house deputy press secretary
karine jean-pierre instead traveled with
the president jensaki put out a
statement about this
where she said on wednesday in
coordination with senior leadership at
the white house and the medical team i
made the decision
not to travel with the four on the
foreign trip with the president due to a
family emergency which was members of my
household testing positive for covid19
since then i have quarantined and tested
negative via pcr for covet on wednesday
thursday friday and saturday however
today i tested positive for covet while
i have not had close contact in person
with the president or senior members of
the white house staff since wednesday
and tested negative for four days after
that last contact i am disclosing
today's positive test out of an
abundance of transparency i last saw the
president on tuesday when we sat outside
more than six feet apart and wore masks
thanks to the vaccine i have only
experienced mild symptoms which has
enabled me to continue working from home
i plan to return to work in person at
the conclusion of the 10-day quarantine
following a negative rapid test which is
an additional white house requirement
beyond cdc guidance taken
out of an abundance of caution so she's
vaccinated so is joe biden outside masks
two vaccinated people transmission risk
is almost zero i say n i don't say zero
because strange things happen when you
have bell curve distributions of things
and unexplainable things happen
incredibly unlikely that joe biden would
get coveted in this case
she correctly assesses
her risk is lower and her risk of a
serious case is lower because she's
vaccinated that's true now there are
people opportunists and just ignorant
people who will see this and once again
much like with the death of colin powell
say this is proof that the vaccines
don't work and of course any one
anecdote
doesn't tell us much about at a
population level what does and doesn't
work about vaccines the fact that colin
powell died despite being vaccinated
given that he was 84 and
immunocompromised in more than one way
doesn't really tell us anything about
the effect at a population level of
vaccination in much the same way when
gensake says thanks to the vaccine i
have mild symptoms
that's not really an empirical statement
statistically speaking she's likely to
have fewer symptoms thanks to being
vaccinated any individual though
it's harder to make such a statement but
her general assessment is correct by
being vaccinated
she's at lower risk for a serious case
and unfortunately there are many people
who either don't understand the science
or don't want to understand it because
they have preconceived notions or
desires about what they believe the
vaccine to do
where they will say what's the point of
getting vaccinated saki was vaccinated
and she got it well she's she's working
at home and she seems to feel mostly
okay so that's the latest
very unlikely that joe biden um
could have
received the virus or
been what's the word that she would have
spread the virus to joe biden
in the situation that was described
particularly when she continued testing
negative for several days
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p here's a viewer's
opinion
about whether it's time for progressives
to just kill the bill because it's had
so much gutted this is the spending and
infrastructure bills that bernie sanders
discussed earlier in today's program
hey david i just finished listening to
your segment about the
now gutted
infrastructure bill and how
more and more is getting pulled out to
uh
appease joe manchin and and others i'm
with you i'm at the point where i think
that
progressives just need to say no there's
nothing in here for us we don't want it
better than that though i think what
should be done
if possible i don't know if it is but
bring it to a vote
bring it to the floor and
force mansion and force cinema to vote
no on it
and then that way there's no denying
where
they are where anyone else is on
their position regarding this bill and
regarding
help for the american people who pay
their salaries yeah i'm not against
eventually just get a vote and if they
really aren't going to go anywhere get
them on record voting against it i'm
fine with that as i said i was fine with
it during the entire force the vote on
medicare thing that uh medicare for all
that aoc you know i'm not against
getting people on record i'm more about
trying to actually achieve something so
i don't need to immediately force a vote
right now if there's a chance that like
for example as bernie sanders said and
we played the clip earlier if he is
still working on getting prescription
drug cost controls in the bill i'd
rather wait a little longer and actually
get that in the bill and pass it because
that's better for more people um
ultimately though i do think that there
has to be some kind of limit and if we
get to that limit and progressives are
better uh served by just killing the
bill
at a certain point you got to just vote
and get joe manchin to vote no and and
get chris kirsten cinema to vote no and
get him on record i'm not against that
when the time comes it actually does
seem that at least bernie sanders
believes some substantive progress could
be made and some major things could be
put in the bill
we have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about this just
completely botched revelation or
announcement from facebook that they are
changing its company name to meta
a lot of people misunderstanding
thinking facebook is now facebook the
app is now called meta no this is a
corporate change google is now alphabet
and it's still google.com everything's
still called google google nest google
home etc we will talk about um a
strawberry pop tart case
that is one of 400 lawsuits that a
lawyer has filed
and when we talk about frivolous
we've got to talk about this and i think
it'll be an interesting discussion and
then also outrage
over a southwest airlines pilot saying
let's go brandon which is the new
it's it's a
code for f joe biden that comes from a
sort of
confusion during a car race that took
place we'll explain it all but a
southwest airlines pilot essentially
saying f joe biden during his pre-flight
announcement
to passengers audible gasps were heard
in the cabin and demands for the pilot
to be fired he should be fired he should
be fired political statements um i
believe are against company policy for
pilots for basically every airline so we
will talk about that and much more when
producer pat joins me on today's bonus
show get instant access by signing up at
joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com pacman